let me start by saying how much I love
this movie is one of my favorites of the
year I have nothing but positive things
to say thank you and I'm out you have a
fantastic I'm joking you too so I am
curious though before I get into the
film uh if besides the holdovers if
someone has never seen anything you've
done before what is the first thing
you'd like them watching and why I would
say hi fidelian
doite I think it gives a a good
roundabout
uh explanation of me as an
artist um and that those were just
really uh Pinnacle moments in my career
where I felt like of High Fidelity I was
able to really push the bounds and allow
to really just be free um which felt so
good and with Dolomite to work with
Eddie and to be able to spar with him in
that way I'm very proud of that
both of those projects all of them but
in particular to what you're asking yeah
I would say those I haven't seen High
Fidelity but what but Dolomite is
incredible thank you please go see high
fideli I swear there's a lot of TV out
there it's it's very hard during the
holidays please speaking of TV though
you're not going to watch it uh I don't
know if I can but I was just I'm being
honest I have so much to watch no I know
it's overwhelming U but I will say that
I also love you on only murders thank
you and so I have to ask you what is it
like being with that group it is the
best job I've ever had in regards to the
economics of going to work for long
hours in a cold Warehouse in the dark
that is my favorite place to do that at
they are the best there's something
about them that is so Inspire no I know
what it's about them inspiring they are
the age they are they have accomplished
the things they have accomplished Merl
included now in the the mix and yet all
three of them come to work like giddy
little kids as if this was their first
gig and that blows my mind and I just
sit at their feet and absorb it all and
take it all in they give amazing advice
they're so caring and kind and they just
are always like you know what can we do
next how do we make this better how can
we make it funnier are you kidding me
all the things they've accomplished and
they're still trying to chase the thing
and it's so moving was beautiful so
jumping into why I get to talk to you
obviously Alexander Payne calls and you
know Paul Gatti all this stuff you're
probably going to say yes but what was
it like actually reading the script for
the first time and seeing how awesome
this role was well to be completely
transparent with you when Alexander
called me I don't it's been two years
but I I don't believe I had the script
first and I actually didn't know who
Alexander Payne was when he uh reached
out but when I did get this script for
me and I don't think I even knew that
Paul was connected for me the biggest
thing was it was a woman who got to be
real and authentic and in her feelings
unapologetically and for that for a
woman and a woman of color we do not see
much of that in cinema and television
and so have an opportunity to depict
that I was like absolutely sign me up
for it was there a day on on the shoot
you what's being what's in front of you
that you had circled in terms of I
cannot wait to film that scene or oh my
God I I am dreading filming that scene
no none of it honestly none of it well
you know and to it
Alexander prepared us and and and in a
way that it just really felt like we
were tell we didn't film the whole movie
in sequential order but it kind of felt
that way and so with that being said
there was just a ease and a flow we
filmed natural lighting you know in the
real circumstances there was no fake
snow there was no fake cold it was very
real there's no Studio you know so it
the world was all around us and and
encompassing us and so I was up for all
of it in that regard there was nothing
really that I was like oh God I don't
want to do or I guess I that I really
wanted to
do uh I'm not sure I really just was
really excited about all I I was I
didn't dread the cigarettes but the
cigarettes became my co-star in a way
that I was it it's a whole thing with
cigarettes that I don't think people
understand especially it's different to
take a picture of someone smoking across
the street and there's another thing to
film a movie in which you're smoking the
smoke can go different places it can get
in your eyes you're starting to cry well
you don't necessarily want to cry at
this point it's a whole thing so that
was the only thing thing that I was like
uh um but eventually we became friends
and we were able to figure it's a rhythm
knowing when to drag it am I going to
blow it out now am I going to talk how
am I going to hold it now I got this
thing in my hand am I going to try and
dare and do a scene where it's dangling
out my mouth and have a whole
conversation it's a whole it's like an
appendant it's a whole thing yeah I I I
you're so right and so many people don't
understand that is why there's only so
many food and drinks in a movie because
all of that it it requires so much more
oh yes oh yes that that cigarette is
complicated
but he was adamant about it when I did
get the job he sent two large boxes of
cartons of cigarettes to me and he was
like get started cuz I don't I don't
smoke at all uh and it's true he was
like it'll tell on you if you don't know
how to handle it how to finesse how to
pull it that kind of thing everyone will
know and see it on screen and so I had
lots of practice so much so that
sometimes we would redo a take cuz he'd
be like the cigarette upstage D just try
it again H which is amazing and I was
like okay let's get it together um but
no it was wonderful I'm always C I love
talking to actors and I'm always curious
about the way actors like to prepare so
hypothetically you have a really big
scene on a Monday you know it's
emotional or really it's going to
require a lot out you how early on
before that that Monday are you breaking
it down and thinking about it and how
much are you leaving to like in the
moment so what I like to do is I like to
dive in immediately and do all the
backstory and the homework if you will
the text analysis the background story
who they are where they're going where
they came from before I even start
filming so that when we now come to any
scene I can just play Within the given
circumstance an es and more importantly
really connect and listen with my
co-star be open and receptive to what my
director is saying and not be bogged
down by let me figure out who this
person is and I try not to amp up the
Big scenes because a lot of times the
hype kills it and that it doesn't go
necessarily where you want it or in you
amping up you've actually been giving
away the
performance it's like almost like a
little balloon that you let air out you
know what I mean like you're leaking out
the performance all throughout the day
by a trying to fabricate and be in this
moment so I actually do the opposite I
tell jokes happy cheery watch cartoons
all this stuff so that then I have space
to go there on that note I really want
to say one more time how awesome you are
in this movie love it so much have a
fantastic day thank you you
too